batman roboter wartet mit einem
fledermaus gleichen roboter auf sich hat
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei kriegseinsätzen
herzlich willkommen und los geht's
es ist schon wie schnell die roboter
entwicklung vor sich geht und der advan
roboter ist ein neuer meilenstein der
vollkommen neue fähigkeiten hat schon
oft haben wir hier auf clixoom über
roboter berichtet einmal ging es um
einen op roboter also für die medizin
die sogenannten smart psycho autonomes
robert kurz genannt war ist ein für die
medizin vielversprechender operation
roboter der mit hilfe seines optischen
3d tracking system höchst präzise
operationen durchgeführt hatte ein
anders mal ging es um einen kakerlaken
roboter der durch enge wege oder tunnel
manövrieren kann die links sind
natürlich alle in der video beschreibung
jetzt geht es aber um einen batman
roboter beziffert um einen jackpot so
lautet die offizielle bezeichnung des
neuen flugroboter der university of
wie der name schon verrät orientiert
sich dieser an der in deutschland
zukünftig vom aussterben bedrohten
mikrochip terra oder auch einfach nur
fledermaus besonders angetan hat es den
forschern die ab der fledermaus sich
fortzubewegen zitat fledermäuse haben
wohl den ausgefeiltesten angetriebenen
flug mechanismus unter den tieren wie
die wandlungsfähigen eigenschaften ihrer
flügel belegen führt am ende mit neuen
konstruktionen wie einem kohlefaser
skelett um silikon flughaut gelang es
den wissenschaftlern tatsächlich diesen
ausgefallenen flug mechanismus in form
eines roboters umzusetzen
wie ihr seht kommt der beck bot schon
wirklich sehr nah an sein vorbild heran
wie die fledermäuse in jedem noch so
erdenkliche lücke fliegen kann soll auch
der bet bot die letzten erdenklichen
einsatzbereiche der flug robotik
erschießen er kann enge kurven fliegen
extrem schnell die flugrichtung wechseln
oder auch in den sturzflug übergeben
nicht zuletzt auch weil von dem bett bot
keine gefahr ausgeht kann er gegenüber
drohnen viel flexibler eingesetzt werden
und drohnen will gefährlich wie
gefährlich die drohung der zukunft
hinter handel im übrigen hier im video
geklärt kriegt drauf wenn euch das thema
interessiert und wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat aber nur dann
dann können wirklich so
hier abonnieren draufklicken und
vergesse ich den klick auf die glocke
und was glaubt ihr
so könnten die fledermaus roboter zum
einsatz kommt sind sie vielleicht auch
eine gefährliche waffe zb ich bin auf
eure vorschläge und ideen gespannt und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran